[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans point de vue
l'émission quotidienne de décryptage de
l'actualité dé change d'opinion sur
cette même actualité
alors de quoi allons nous parler
aujourd'hui avec mes quatre invités
d'élite
et bien tout d'abord nous reviendrons
sur les élections parlement catalan hier
qui ont donné lieu à la victoire des
formations un des formations
indépendantistes qui obtiennent 70 des
135 sièges les compte tenu de
l'étroitesse de leur majorité de la
réalité de leurs divisions politiques ne
s'agit pas ne s'agit-il pas là d'une
victoire à la pyrrhus
nous évoquerons ensuite le voyage des
manuels macron au niger pour noël auprès
des hommes de l'opération barkan pour
nous demander si le président habib x
est un bon chef de guerre et plus
généralement nous interroger sur ses
rapports avec l'armée française qui sont
parfois tumultueux troisième sujet
quelque chose qui ressemble qui commence
à ressembler un serpent de mer la place
de nicolas hulot dans le gouvernement
hier le ministre de la transition
écologique a boudé la clôture des états
généraux de l'alimentation
au point d'alimenter justement de
nouvelles rumeurs sur son possible
départ du gouvernement
ce matin une rencontre avec edouard
philippe le premier ministre a débouché
sur de grandes déclarations d'amour
réciproque mais nous nous demanderons
quand même si hulot a vraiment une
utilité dans ce gouvernement ou s'il en
est d'une certaine manière l'otage
enfin la lumière des récentes
déclarations du président et du ministre
de la culture françoise nyssen nous
parlerons de ce vrai serpent de mer
qu'est la télévision publique en france
est-elle réformable et d'ailleurs
faut-il la réforme et ce sera la double
question que je poserai à mes invités
mes invités justement qui sont-ils
d'abord le précieux benjamin grange
président de dentsu consulting grâce à
qui nous connaissons mieux l'état
d'opinion des français bon ça va en
vis-à-vis la police de la classe
politique vous est aussi l'auteur d'un
livre chez acta le dirigeant et
l'accélération numérique avec nous aussi
l'indispensable daniel bilalian d'or
l'écran l'ancien directeur des sports de
france messieurs c'est l'ancien
présentateur du jt de france 2 et auteur
d'un formidable et c'est que je vous
conseille à tous à offrir d'ailleurs
pour les périodes de noël sur les
exploits de prisonniers français durant
la seconde guerre
les évadés aux presses de la cité à côté
de vous l'indépassable périco légasse un
des piliers de l'hebdomadaire marianne
qui publie un numéro double pour cette
période de noël sur la grande histoire
du panache français est votre dernier
livre péricaud s'intitule à table
citoyens pour échapper à la malbouffe et
sauver les paysans français tout un
programme
aux éditions du cerf et enfin
l'incomparable génie bastille
journalistes aux pages débats opinion du
figaro firefox directrice de la revue
limite votre dernier livre également
publié aux éditions du cerf s'intitule
adieu mademoiselle la défaite des femmes
alors on commence donc avec ce vote hier
au parlement catalan qui offert une
courte majorité au bloc indépendantiste
mais c'est le parti anti
indépendantistes ciudadanos centre
centre libéral on peut dire qui est
arrivé en tête avec 25% des voix et 37
élus résultat est bien ce matin et hier
soir et ce matin chacun des deux camps
revendiquent est d'une certaine d'une
certaine manière la victoire se
féliciter du résultat
la preuve en images avec iniesta rima
d'as et carlos plus de monde qu'à damas
classique avec comme résultat comme
l'instrument d'un soldat comme première
force politique en catalogne que la
meilleure ia social en catalogne en
faveur de la colonie o'connell resto il
aux partis nationalistes à son camarade
nombre étant la catalogne en catalogne à
santos
[Applaudissements]
ils partent en développement match en
cinq points 5 avec la balade
jenkins quelle parade de la generalitat
alors avant d'entrer dans le détail de
cette ténébreuse affaire benjamin grange
est ce que ces histoires de catane 1
intéresse les français
alors elle intéresse un peu mode est un
peu modérément les français en tout cas
on sait très bien où elle gagne on est
où elle perdant puisque quand on regarde
les réseaux sociaux très clairement le
grand perdant c'est rajoy qui depuis le
démarrage a finalement mal géré cette
comment dire l'ensemble de la situation
et avec un point et un point d'orgue qui
a été cette crise où il a envoyé l'armée
et on lui opposait finalement cette
cette femme ensanglantée déclencher de
l'émotion et donc l'interrogation qui ne
l'interrogation qu'on se fait quand on
lit tout ça c'est comment at il fait
pour si mal gérée si sous-estimé
finalement l'ennemi depuis le démarrage
est donc c'est vraiment ça qui est qui
c'est vraiment ça qui sort et je crois
qu'il a minimisé la situation en tout
cas c'est comme ça que les l'ensemble
des témoignages se manifeste sur les
réseaux sociaux donné le but d'ailleurs
vous avez aussi l'impression que c'est
avant tout une défaite de rajoy il faut
le rappeler que le parti conservateur je
crois qu'elle devait les derniers partis
représentés au parlement catalan
maintenant et a fait un tout petit score
je pense que si c'était le sujet n'était
pas aussi grave on pourrait parler d'une
véritable comédie de boulevard
c'est un vaudeville depuis hier avec
l'amant qui se planque dans l'oubli
pendant que le mari rentré que l'autre
ressort franchement pour un français ça
a quelque chose d'incompréhensible en
même temps c'est vrai qu'à mon avis le
premier ministre espagnol a fait une
erreur très grave
lors du premier référendum qui n'étaient
pas officielles selon les autorités
espagnoles pourquoi ne l'at-il pas
laisser ce se dérouler en dix ans le
résultat ne veut nouveau rien on va en
faire un vrai et je pense que un certain
nombre de gens hier soir qui ont voté
contre lui c'est à dire contre l'espagne
n'auraient pas voté de la même façon je
pense que je suis toujours étonné quand
des hommes politiques qui ont autour
d'eux
des conseillers puissent se lancer dans
des affaires comme celle-ci c'est
vraiment quelque chose c'est quelqu'un
qui se met en colère d'un seul coup
qu'il y une casse les pieds je vais me
matter etc
je veux dire cette fois faire de la
politique que de faire ça ou sinon
s'appelle donald trump mais ça c'est
encore ans au sujet
périco légasse l'impression que c'était
mal géré cette affaire par rajoy avant
tout quand on se dit le chef d'un
gouvernement d'une grande démocratie
qu'est devenu l'espagne après avoir été
une dictature pendant 40 ans on n'en
voit pas la force publique
or c'était la police mais c'est vrai que
c'est la force armée on n'en voit pas la
force publique ont leur voix contre des
de la sédition je ne sais pas des
émeutes va pas contre les gens qui
veulent s'exprimer en votant et comme
l'a dit daniel ce référendum ils étaient
plus symboliques institutionnelle
puisque la constitution espagnole et
c'est tout le problème ne reconnaît pas
le droit aux communautés autonomes de
s'autodéterminer
donc il prenait acte qu'une partie des
catalans qui n'étaient pas majoritaires
voté pour l'indépendance je leur ai dit
on va ouvrir un dialogue et il serait
sorti très grand d'y envoyer la force
publique contre des gens qui se rendent
aux urnes avec les images qu'on a eu des
gens matraque et d'une violence
incarcéré des parlementaires et des
gouvernants élu par un parlement car les
indépendantistes catalans qui ne sont
jamais que des démocrates chrétiens et
des sociaux-démocrates et des noms n'y a
pas que ça mais c'est le parti au
pouvoir pdg demande c'est c'est bayrou
c'est entre bayrou et évoqué dans nos
retrouvailles ou macron c'est un modéré
libéral tout ce qu'il ya de plus gentil
rappelons quand même je suis basque au
pays basque et la violence il ya eu des
morts il ya une organisation de
libération nationale qui est devenu
terroriste avec une violence terrible
les catalans en 40 ans et pendant
franchise ea n'a jamais cassé un carreau
ils ont jamais brisé une vitre c'est des
gens qui protestaient dans son la
sardane en parlant leur langue
c'est un exemple de mouvements de
libération d'aspiration nationale qui
l'a fait de façon pacifié tolérante et
démocratique et on en voit la force
armée
donc nous savons quelque chose ce soir
c'est que monsieur rajoy qui appartient
à partie qui fut la partie franquiste
qui s'est reconverti tout à fait tout à
fait légitimement dan principe a eu ce
réflexe d'un nationalisme le vrai
nationaliste dans l'histoire c'est rajoy
qui au nom de l'espagne una gran
délivrer une indivisible a dit je vais
envoyer contre la sédition séparatistes
catalan qui sont des partis politiques
totalement légaux et légitimes
ils envoyaient la force armée et des
catalans qui sont des gens responsables
lui ont donné une leçon démocratie je
considère que les gens qui ont voté pour
les partis indépendantistes qui ne font
que 47 % le parti ciudadanos il n'a fait
que récupérer 8 sièges du parti ya pas
de puits a pas d'anti espalionnaise plus
d'autant que ce parti centriste il est
trés autonomistes ce qu'ils veulent pas
c'est l'indépendance mail à 100% des
partis catalans sont autonomistes faut
bien le dire ils sont partis
autonomistes et bien aujourd'hui les
choses se répartit le dialogue va
s'ouvrir puis d'idées montady moi je
demande à négocier car ' aujourd'hui si
monsieur rhin fouilles n'ont que si
vraiment c'est un homme politique
responsable et compétent il démissionne
il a été désavoué par ses propres règles
demandé la démission de rabah envie de
partir il a perdu il a joué un pari très
risqué
pardonnez moi il a mis ses sur la table
il a totalement perdu fond et forme
c'est à dire que les catalans ont
maintenu les partis nationalistes
souverainistes au pouvoir et son parti
le parti populaire a été partiellement
désavoué il a été éliminé il ya un
élément nouveau il ya un cocus de
l'histoire dans la politique française
pour vous gars il a déjà pas de bol déjà
pas pour à ses errements et s'appelle
manuel valls il est à le soutenir il
aurait pu seraient ceux de nantes
il est allé soutenir le parti de rajoy
lui qui soit disant une fils de
républicains espagnols il est allé
soutenir
je l'écouté en espagne puisque je pari à
tenir un discours quasiment nue ou
francky sur l'unité de l'espagne et la
sédition et là moi je pense que valoir
qu'il arrête de faire de la politique il
s'achète un camping car avec raccord ils
vont faire une belle balade ils sont
aussi dus là que l'auteur n'est pas
encore là avant de l'un par le génie
parce que justement de regarder
d'écouter ce qu'a dit manuel valls après
l'annoncé des résultats
hier soir l'agenda indépendantiste
lui-même s'est heurté à un mur
les entreprises 3000 qui sont partis
l'union européenne qui a dit très
clairement qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir
de devoir indépendantistes pour la
catalogne et du côté de l'état espagnol
par aussi le fait qu'on a appliqué de
manière très ferme l'état de droit donc
il n'y a pas vraiment de solution il ya
une forme d'impasse et il faudra sortir
de cette impasse me semble-t-il jeudi
très modestement et je suis pas un
acteur de la vie politique espagnole il
par le dialogue par le respect par l'
écoute the bat c
discours de manuel valls ou vraiment
mieux valait siéger à l'assemblée
nationale où il a été élu puisque le
conseil d'état lui accorder son élection
et on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs qu'il avait
déposée et 0 abonnement et qu'il était
très peu présent aux séances donc au
lieu de faire la tournée de l'espagne
j'aimerais mieux qu'ils soient présents
à l'assemblée nationale et je vois pas
trop ce qu'il vient faire dans la police
cela dit le contraire d'une impasse vous
êtes d'accord avec cette idée conduit
dans une impasse quand même aujourd'hui
oui alors après moi je pense que je
pense que d'une part n'importe quel état
nation réagi comme l'a fait madrid c'est
à dire qu'on n'organise pas comme ça un
référendum sauvage sans sens en forme
sans respecter l'état de droit donc
n'importe quel état nation en européens
auraient réagi de la même manière
simplement et je pense bien d'autres
d'autre part qu' il faut relativiser la
victoire des indépendantistes en soit
c'est la première fois depuis 1977
qu'un parti non indépendantiste parvient
en tête des élections le parti sur
d'ananas donc il ya quand même un
phénomène majeur et étant donnée
justement les images extrêmement de
victimisation extrêmes qui sont comme si
on passait en boucle sur la télévision
catalane et c'est en menant à puce
attendant mon avis à un sursaut des
nationalistes encore plus grand en ils
ont retrouvé leurs niveaux de 2015 et on
y est super nes en tête ça il ya 4 2 %
de participation pardon en n'ayant plus
les indécis vont voter et rajoy seconde
à 140 est quand même mais nous parce que
lundi il a libéré les voix des autres
la somme des parties non indépendantiste
exactement la même sauf que ça c'est
groupé sur une seule entité est donc
effectivement en nombre de sièges
il est premier mais aujourd'hui les
années 70 j'ai fait j'ai fait des contre
attend sur le micro les indépendantistes
ont gagné il va pas vous entendre c'est
de me protégeant profil et les questions
mais d'une question justement sur sûr
les réseaux sociaux le droitier incendie
c'est une victoire à l'arraché au niveau
des indépendantistes qui ne parviendront
pas à s'unir ce que c'est quand même
passé à la question très bien les airs
de meylan dix ans on peut à métaux qui
va gagner mais ça fait un mois vont
soutenir un centre droit centre gauche
une extrême gauche à moi qu'on nous
explique les jeux sans des séditieux
laissé par nous mais on parle de
politique oui justement via un mouvement
d'extrême gauche qui a un certain nombre
de députés je crois à lui débuté comment
il va s'entendre avec le centre de
rennes centre gauche justin est d'avoir
été le plus extrémiste parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que cette coalition
indépendantiste c'est un exemple à
suivre ailleurs elle va à peu près de
wauquiez à besancenot
voilà évidemment ça nous choque moins
france parce qu'on ne sait de s'insulter
ils se sont mis d'accord sur un enjeu
qui est la souveraineté de la catalogne
dans le cadre d'une espagne qui a refusé
une amélioration du statut d'autonomie
qui avait été approuvé par le parlement
catalan par le gouvernement espagnol et
par le parlement espagnol en 2006
monsieur rajoy quand il est revenu au
pouvoir a fait casser cette clause par
le conseil constitutionnel quand les
juges sont venus majoritairement qu'il
faut rappeler qui a lancé cette grande
amélioration de l'autonomie c'est le
parti socialiste catalan monsieur pascal
maragall un camarade de manuel valls qui
quand il était président la généralitat
tu es un moment donné socialistes ont
pris la tête c'est pas la première fois
qu'un parti dans l'indépendant
distillerie la catalogne il lance ce
processus d'amélioration du statut de la
catalogne pour avoir une amélioration
fiscale
tout le monde s'était mis d'accord tout
et institutions nationales et régionales
espagnole et catalane était d'accord la
paix est et a été atteinte et rajoy le
nationalistes espagnols vengeurs arriver
dit je casse sa disposition
les catalans ont dit bah si c'est comme
ça on quitte la maison espagne puisqu'on
peut pas voir tout ce statut mais il
n'était pas du tout pour la dépendance
il les a poussé à vous dans leurs
retranchements
donc aujourd'hui on a beau dire la
majorité elle est claire il ya 70 sièges
ils en ont perdu 2 me sur 90% des
votants ils vont évidemment s'entendre
on va peut-être pas que je demande qui
sera président mais aujourd'hui les
catalans ont clairement exprimé de façon
massive déterminer dans un contexte qui
était évidemment édifiant qu'ils veulent
la souveraineté est aujourd'hui madrid 6
sur les gens raisonnables
je pense que monsieur rajoy va dégager
peut-être que monsieur rivera le parti
sur d'adams le centriste va devenir
président du conseil s'il ya des
élections législatives en espagne et la
solution est pacifique et tout le monde
sera très content ça se passera très
bien j'annonce à tout le monde à tous
les photos les prédicteur de malheurs
que la situation catalan va se régler
dans la sérénité dans l'accord non
mais qu'attend on ne peut parler
répandre l indépendance sur le rac à
celle permise à aucun média français de
la gauche et se relâche pas autonomistes
s'ils ne veulent pas parce que quand ils
ont été on leur a dit non alors donc si
j'ai du mal à suivre la wii ça fait
penser aux corses qui veulent
l'indépendance mais avec la sécurité
sociale française
un ça à peu près ça dont là j'avoue je
pige pas il ya des gens qui nous
écoutent qui comprennent pas je veux
dire quand vous êtes autonome il me dit
je suis autonomistes il ya des mots en
français vous êtes vous êtes
indépendantiste vous êtes
indépendantiste mais je reviens de tout
ce que vous avez dit c'est que je
reviens à ce que si monsieur rares or il
n'avait pas fait l'imbécile n'avait pas
fait l'imbécile
il n'avait pas fait intervenir la police
de manière brutale lors de du pseudo
référendum hier et bien c'est laisser
les unionistes qui l'aurait emporté
assez largement
si vous n'êtes pas un grand je n'ai pas
l'impression que les catalans ont le
sentiment que l'europe ne les suit pas
dans cette affaire parce que d'une
semaine ils ont voulu passer par-dessus
l'état nation en déclarant leur
autonomie dans l'indépendance est
manifestement toute l'europe est
d'accord pour condamner leur stratégie
est ce qu'ils sont pas déçus à votre
avis de cette absence de soutien de des
autres nations enfin la mode de l'europe
des régions étaient
aujourd'hui est un peu en perte de
vitesse c'est-à-dire il ya plus ce
discours-là à bruxelles
avant on avait dit voilà le
donc c'est le jouer la carte des
régionalismes pour affaiblir les états
nations aujourd'hui on voit que
bruxelles dans un cadre très tendue et
des populismes
qui sont qui sont en embuscade un peu
partout dans tous les pays d'europe
je joue la carte des états nations et
notamment avec évidemment l'élection d'
emmanuel macron président de européen et
s'est dit voilà maintenant on va jouer
la carte des états nations et essayer de
ne pas souffler sur les braises d
apprendre autistes et des régionalismes
parce que ce serait alimenté populisme
est aujourd'hui bockel bon s'en prendre
non plus sans condamner extrêmement
fermement les régionalistes en tout cas
est fait et beaucoup moins et beaucoup
plus soft sur ce sujet qu'elle n'a pu
l'être auparavant jamais grand chose et
cette impression aussi que l'europe est
finalement assez prudent avec se
régionalise qu'elle a un peu oui je
n'aurais pas que j'aurais pas tout à
fait cet angle là moi la vraie question
que je me pose c'est le fait générateur
c'est à dire que cette crise est l'aîné
simplement de gens qui sont réveillés un
jour alors même s'ils sont pas réveillés
avec ces dix là mais en disant tiens et
si on devenait indépendant ce n'est pas
suffisant que pour reconnaître de la
part des autres populations le fait que
c'est un vrai fait générateur et que
c'est légitime donc donc la manière dont
est née finalement l'ensemble de ces
événements
déjà le porte en soi une forme de
suspicion sur wii ce qu est ce que ça va
voyez c est donc ce point là et il doit
ya un mois il doit être tranchée quel
est le sens mais ces nationalistes et
souverainistes catalan je les connais
bien ils sont profondément européen ils
veulent juste gagner une étape
ils veulent être adhérent direct de
l'europe ils ne veulent pas passer par
égoïsme en espagnol est un gouvernement
corrompu ils veulent pas passer par le
prisme espagnol ils sont là depuis des
siècles ils sont profondément européen
barcelone est une grande métropole de
l'idéal européen elle est porteuse des
valeurs culturelles et économiques et il
dit après tout on est à même comme des
dizaines d'autres états qui sont dans
l'europe grand constitué des
états-nations qu'on a reconnu on
applaudit la slovénie la slovaquie tous
ces pays là au kosovo et les catalans
qui ont plus de légitimité que c est à
cela va advenir des gens voudraient
devenir ailleurs y est allé à bruxelles
le gouvernement belge a soutenu monsieur
plus du démon qui l'ont pas remis et
monsieur juncker équation entournures
par contre quand il s'agit de dire que
l'ecosse et de se séparer d'angleterre
parce qu'elle veut rester européenne
tout le monde trouve ça formidable et
quand les catalans disent on veut faire
comme les causes on voudrait devenir
directement européen ah non vous êtes
d'affreux séparatistes séditieux faut
accorder nos violons et avoir un
discours un peu plus cohérent
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya un
phénomène global et compagnie des
annales et publiée dans les pages débats
du figaro un article de gilles martin
chauffier qui atteint voilà breton qui a
écrit un petit à petit et c'est ce qui
s'appelle du bonheur d'être breton
déréglé région contre les nations en
disant que finalement il va un phénomène
global de régionalisation et que dans la
mondialisation pour survivre il fallait
jouer les régions et l'europe contre les
états nations moi je pense que je suis
n'a pas de la subsidiarité je pense
qu'on peut avoir plusieurs fidélité
l'europe l'état nation et la région et
qu'il faut voilà à chaque je suis pour
un maximum des centres décentralisation
mais ce n'est pas incompatible dans
l'union européenne est prête à adopter
de settat silva paye parlement wallon
encore un parlement régional des vrais
démocrates kirby est ce qu on peut juste
lire le texte pour savoir ce qu'il ya
dedans on se rend compte qu'il ya des
clauses qui sont incompatibles intérêts
de l'europe
si l'union européenne d'une seule voix
tous nos chefs d'état et de gouvernement
signe le ceta c'est à dire une abolition
une renonciation au droit européen
il est normal que l'europe financière
libéral soit remplacé par l'europe des
peuples est aujourd'hui à des peuples
qui disent nous ne voulons plus de cette
europe de la commission et les systèmes
financiers de 2008
nous voulons avoir une europe qui est
représentatif nos intérêts les catalans
les écossais et toutes les régions sont
les ultras d'européens voilà qui mettra
libérales et productivistes
europe celle que nous sommes que nous
avons rêvé en s'attendre à ce que
certaines libertés s'il allait grandir
qu'elles ressentent les citoyens
vraiment beaucoup de citoyens en france
et que l'europe est capable de s'occuper
de la taille de nos fromages et de la
hausse est de nourrir de nos coûts de
nos vins mais si on est incapable de
trouver une politique de l'immigration
recouvrant l'ensemble de l'europe
absolument elle sait qu'elle s'est par
ailleurs la taille de nos fromages
l'europe cox police aux bijoux jeudi 2 3
commentaires qui sont sur les réseaux
sociaux libéral hans von sidow c'est une
victoire parlementaire mais en
pourcentage des votes les
non-indépendantistes ont quand même 51
points 5 % des votes des
indépendantistes n'ont pas gagné la
majorité ils en sont au même point et
hugo gagneux nous dit à vouloir unifier
les peuples on les divise l'europe est
en train de créer des aspirations
régionales qui ne pourront se résoudre
que par l'indépendance de ces régions et
ce sera la fin de l'europe
on quitte l'europe ont traversé la
méditerranée pour le deuxième sujet
emmanuel macron passera donc son premier
noël deux présidents loin du sapin que
laurent delahousse nous a montré la
semaine dernière au niger avec les 500
soldats français de barkan qui se trouve
sur la base de niamey alors génie
bastille on se souvient de sa descente
des champs-elysées lors de son élection
en commande car ensuite du psychodrame
avec le général de villiers geslin de
vie y est d'ailleurs qu'ils n'ont pas
tout à fait terminé avec cette affaire
si ton surnom juste son interview dans
valeurs actuelles
ce week-end ou une dit je ne regrette en
rien ma décision je n'aurais pas pu
continuer à regarder les soldats dans
les yeux en sachant qu'on ne leur
donnait pas tous les moyens nécessaires
à l'exercice de leurs missions dont on
voit que cette histoire les c'est quand
même des traces il en est aujourd'hui
selon vous emmanuel macron avec l'armée
française est ce que je fais apaisée ce
que ces informations assez voilà de va
et vient entre entre une espèce de
séduction et même temps déception
puisque départ évidemment et il avait
essayé de remonter les champs elysées
avec ce gros camions
command car voilà c'est comme ça et ça
va donner une image assez militaire et
militaires
pas de quasiment 2 générale le chef des
armées il avait parlé de mes hommes un
moment dans un déplacement en
s'appropriant la salle paul voilà et
mais après il y avait une inquiétude
avec la nomination de sylvie goulard qui
me les normes européennes et qui était
pas vraiment dans la ligne de l'armée
française et avec cette déception avec
le général de villiers alors là il est
en train d'essayer de retrouver le coup
depuis ces dernières semaines puisque à
une politique étrangère très très
volontariste et ils sauront ils seront
beaucoup à l'étranger pour féliciter des
soldats français il a fait applaudir des
soldats français au burkina faso devant
les étudiants burkinabé en disant vous
devez applaudir les soldats français
parce que ils sont là pour vous aider
il a vraiment soutenu un discours
extrêmement de soutien donc voilà encore
une fois si cela se réglera on a mis sur
la dimension budgétaire
il a en effet serrer la ceinture de
l'armée en 2017 mais il a promis qu'en
2018 se serait à nouveau augmenté à voir
si c'est cette promesse sera respectée
je pense que c'est la savait très
important quand on voit le l'état
déplorable des du matériel militaire
dans l'armée française
on se dit que vraiment c'est pas la
priorité des priorités de faire des
coupes budgétaires à cet endroit là
alors les tutos ça qui on a posé la
question considère que emmanuel macron
n'est pas un bon chef de guerre benjamin
grand chose et les impressions quand
même qu'il est qu il a quelque chose à
rattraper qu'il se sert de la notoriété
de l'armée française qui est plutôt
bonne une très bonne opinion même je
crois auprès des français pour essayer
de récupérer cette notoriété mais qu' on
sent qu'il n'y a pas tout à fait de
légitimité à le faire disons qu'il est
au max de sa popularité
pour un président en exercice après
après quelques mois
c'est peut-être ya peut-être un début de
doute sur un socle en bois choses et
notamment sur l'armée c'est ce qu'on a
vu dans le sondage voilà voilà
c'est ce qu'on a fait voilà c'est ce
qu'on a vu dans le sondage c'est ce qui
est ce qui est intéressant et moi ce qui
m'a marqué et l'ins et blom de
communication qui parle d' emmanuel
macron et quand on se remémore
d'ailleurs les premiers meetings de
campagne quand il était quand il était
en campagne c'est la manière dont il la
prend c'est à dire ses premiers meetings
était pas très bon pour voilà et puis
après il est devenu excellent et
finalement il a une capacité à s'adapter
très vite est finalement là où au départ
on peut considérer que c'est une erreur
finalement à retomber sur ses pattes et
à progresser et si il est peut-être
encore il prête un peu le flanc sur le
sujet de l'armée au démarrage vous allez
voir que dans quelques dans quelques
mois ça va être
il y aura plus de tirs a plus de souci
en tout cas sur son image de chef des
armées
vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
daniel bilalian que pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore un bon chef de guerre
mais qu' il va obtenir un lien venez
avantage sur moi c'est qu'il a pas fait
son service militaire
oui 18 mois je confirme voilà un chef
donc non mais on a rendu service à notre
pays si je pense que d'ailleurs le
service militaire avec cette chose
importante c'est que non mais je veux
dire ça c'est un service national qui
servait service national je dire jacques
chirac c'est une des âneries qu'il a
fait parmi d'autres temps d'autres je
veux dire c'était un moment où tous les
français se retrouver ensemble et au
service militaire était particulièrement
intéressant pour les gens qui venaient
du bas de l'échelle
un monsieur comme bernard tapie qui ne
nuit pas tellement par ailleurs à 10 et
à l'armée que je me suis rendu compte de
l'ascendant que je vais sur les autres
sinon j'aurais pas fait la carrière que
j'ai fait ceci mise à part un bon chef
de guerre on peut le reconnaître on
n'aime guère ce que je ne souhaite pas
je veux dire l'armée française était la
première armée du monde en mai 1939 et
1,6 mo six semaines plus tard il y avait
plus l'armée française donc cela dit ce
qu'il est en train de faire en afrique
la notamment lorsqu'il va se rendre en
afrique c'est de dire aux africains
écoutez faudrait peut-être nous aider un
peu plus que vous ne le faites
et ça c'est quelque chose d'un chef de
guerre qui a qui a une idée
la tête qui dit nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment aidé dans les opérations
que nous menons à travers l'afrique
subsaharienne il faut il faut vraiment
nous aider on sent très bien que il a de
ce côté là le sentiment que les choses
ne sont pas ne sont pas véritablement
engagée ensuite il veut aussi que les
autres états européens comme l'allemagne
qui est très réservé dans ce domaine là
vient soutenir l'action notamment au
moyen-orient et chef de guerre au
moyen-orient il l'est parce qu'il est le
premier à avoir reconnu que c'est très
gentil de dire
assad il faut le ceci fausse à assad il
est là donc il faut dans un premier
temps - travailler avec lui c'est ça je
veux dire c'est à dire tenir compte
c'est très joli de faire des envolées
lyriques mais je veux dire il ya un
président qui est là il est là malgré la
guerre il est là malgré tout ce qu'il a
fait et lui a dit et ça c'est un vrai
chef d'état et c'est un vrai chef
militaire dire cette guerre on ne
gagnera pas si d'un côté on essaye de le
supprimer avant même que la peine soit
revue l'impression que c'est un peu de
la communication quand même tous ses
voyages incessants auprès des armes et
où il ya quand même une réelle
conviction derrière tout ça oui le
conflit il a été arrêté il a été
remporté je ne suis pas sûr que si la
politique de financement militaire que
mène emmanuel macron va à terme la
france pourrait intervenir au mali on
sait qu'on a déjà dévoilé les besoins
dead et on sait sur place qui avait des
carences matériel et des carences
logistique eric on est à la limite de la
capacité de la souveraineté militaire de
la france avec le nouveau budget
militaire tel que l'a dit de villiers de
façon très posée c'est un homme très
responsable c'est très inquiétant parce
que la souveraineté militaire de la
france dans une europe où ils appâtent y
aurait une politique commune européenne
un militaire on se dirait mais déléguons
là on voit bien que celle atlantiste qui
parle en disant mais les américains
arguant de problèmes en tout cas là ce
qui dit clairement aux africains nous ne
reviendrons pas donc prenez vos
dispositions
prévoyez l'avenir mais nos jeux ne nous
n'aurons plus les moyens de revenir vous
aider c'est quand même dramatique
quant au fait dire je suis le chef je
suis votre chef quand il à cette
injonction au général de villiers c'est
surprenant d'ailleurs entre la la
carrière des deux hommes oui c'est le
chef des armées parce que c'est pas mal
police française il a pas pour l'instant
le comportement d'un président de la
république chef de guerre ça a l'air
plutôt d'un négociant de
deux rapports diplomatiques et on ne
parle même pas de florence parly qui est
un peu aux abonnés absents je vous
rappelle la ministre de france
et puis par rapport à olemps donc on
peut dire que hollande était peut-être
davantage chef de guerre que macron
paradoxal mais voilà on n'a pas été un
très un mauvais chef de guerre au mali
ce qui va me suis énormément d'attention
sur françois hollande mali or si les
clairacais ce qui les feront non mais
sérieux qui laissera dans l'histoire se
passe à dix mais n'empêche que il a été
en pas de fonderie chef de guerre et
puis mes mac on a pas longtemps pour
l'instant ouvert aucun nouveau front
sachant qu'à deux sujets brûlants la
libye et le yémen
qu'est ce qu'il va faire maintenant
c'est dans ces deux endroits est-ce
qu'il faut retourner en libye et
certains experts disent que c'est
inévitable si on veut rétablir l'ordre
dans cette région et stopper les flux
migratoires et au yémen c'est une
catastrophe humanitaire qui est en cours
et est ce que emmanuel macron va jouer
un rôle pour résoudre ce conflit sachant
que donald trump est là pour le coup aux
abonnés absents et qu'ils laissent leurs
amis samedi de faire regarder en libye
il voulait
il ya quelques mois installé des camps
pour éviter que les les espaces de
transit se passer ça n'a pas existé
c'est en vue du ciel en marche qui va
faire une cuisse mais voilà absolument
mais vous avez raison c'est qu'en
matière militaire le côté matériel de
l'armée c'est très important aujourd'hui
vous avez environ cinq ans alors je suis
un ancien aviateur
donc il ya à peu près 50% des avions
français qui ne sont pas en état de
fonctionner 44% et vous rendez compte
que on transporte nos troupes dans des
dans des avions qui appartiennent à des
pays étrangers comme la russie ou des
pays limitrophes des qui ont des vrais
avions de transport avec une justice non
pour la libye il faut consulter bernard
henri lévy de ces dernières questions
benjamin
est ce qu'on a vraiment l'impression que
c'est comme de la communication quand on
sait que le budget de la défense a chuté
de 11% en disant c'est à dire que comme
le disait tout à l'heure périco légasse
on peut faire des grands discours on
peut aller au niger on peut aller quatre
ou cinq fois en afrique comme c'est le
cas de macron depuis son élection
mais la réalité physique financières
techniques matériels militaires
elle est là c'est à dire qu'en baissant
le budget de 1% en moyenne par an et il
est quand même de plus en plus difficile
de ceux de se déployer dans les dents
des continents fusse-t-il proche de nos
intérêts comme l'afrique est ce que la
communication que la politique était
dissociable de la communication parce
que non après emmanuel macron a ouvert
finalement son son action sous la forme
d'un discours de preuves
d'ailleurs il l'a encore dit la semaine
dernière attendons les éléments de
preuve sur ce domaine aussi il y avait
tenté au congo maintenant on a mal et au
mali enviable merci au pirée goût pour
cette référence littéraire de premier
plan on change de sujet avec nicolas
hulot qui était hier absent de la
clôture des états généraux de
l'alimentation sujets qui vous
intéressent beaucoup péricaud
officiellement pour des raisons d'agenda
mais il a quand même fait savoir ensuite
qu'il était très déçu qu'il y avait
beaucoup de travail de travail à
accomplir sur ce sujet d'où les petites
rumeurs de démission qui sont revenus
comme c'est le cas depuis plusieurs mois
déjà et puis la vue edouard philippe ce
matin il désormais c'est embrassons nous
folleville avec le premier ministre
il en a même profité on va le voir et
l'écouter tout de suite pour dire que
tout ça ces rumeurs c'était des
menteries des médias on écoute je ne
devrais pas être critique vis-à-vis du
monde médiatique mais il va plus vite
que moi donc moi je découvre que je suis
en désaccord alors que je ne suis pas
c'est qu'à un moment donné vous avez
pensé à démissionner suite norme sas et
je les dis ce matin c'est vraiment un
fantasme médiatique me colle à la peau
qui voudrait dire que dès que quelque
chose ne va pas assez vite je poserai ma
démission enfin c'est insupportable et
j'espère que ça avait été le cas on a
rare mea ma place depuis longtemps pas
comme ça que je fonctionne en réalité on
a un peu le sentiment que l'on se
demande parfois ce qu'il fait dans ce
gouvernement vis-à-vis notamment du
ministre de l'agriculture du marais
agriculture stéphane travert on se
souvient du débat sur les cli fosad sur
notre dame des landes sur les pesticides
tueurs d'abeilles
on a cette impression quand même n'est
pas très à l'aise dans ce gouvernement à
moi surtout c'est ici même quand il a
été nommé il avait dit 'tiens emmanuel
macron 20 people avec lui c'est un
people
nicolas hulot alors en plus cette
affaire qui intervient aujourd'hui vient
un moment où il est l'objet de
discussions et de plaisanterie à propos
de sens de son matériel automobile un de
ses nombreuses voitures et résidence
mais ça c'est un peu ridicule parce
qu'on peut être riche est un bon
gouvernant ça n'a pas de sens de dire
faut pas être pauvres pour gouverner ça
n'a pas de sens mais en même temps je
pense qu'il n'a pas de je pense qu'il a
pas de je crois qu'il n'a pas compris le
système politique je veux dire faire de
la politique c'est accepter des choses
ne pas en accepter mais je pense que en
fait pour faire court le véritable
moment où il devra devant l'obstacle
refusé l'obstacle ou le franchir c'est
notre dame des landes parce que là c'est
le sujet ci se dégonfle à ce moment là
il est plus crédible
la question qu'on a posés sur twitter
c'est doit-il effectivement quitté le
gouvernement à ce qu'il faut attendre
notre dame des landes pour le faire ou
est-ce qu'il faut que la seconde avait
un vrai sujet l'alimentation peut-être
qu'il a dit voilà je n'ai pas envie d'y
aller parce que ce n'est pas un sujet
majeur mais notre dame des landes c'est
le sujet majeur depuis 1963 donc mais
les twittos c'est 50 50 sur cette
question c'est de n'avoir servi que de
caution électorale saab sas a bien
marché c'était une prouesse jamais
personne n'avait réussi à décrocher
hulot macron est suffisamment
convaincant et persuasif pour que
nicolas hulot viennent il vient coin
avec des contreparties très précises ça
lui a valu quelques boa constrictor à
avaler depuis bon alors je peux pas tout
avoir il est dans un gouvernement il est
dans une politique collective
le problème c'est que sur les enjeux
grave ou le gouvernement devait trancher
à comprendre une décision
macron est allé dans le sens de hulot
dans les détails dans les enjeux majeurs
il mercredi
la semaine dernière il y avait sur le
réseau territorial
il y avait cette grande clause sur
l'extension des grandes surfaces dont on
sait aujourd'hui que la grande
distribution le fléau sociologiques
culturelles économiques elles supposent
autre gravité montrer que notre
artisanat bien sûr qu'il fallait freiner
et nous apprenons que le gouvernement va
reculer et en plus cela veut guère bercy
n'est pas d'accord mais je pensais que
la france était gouvernée à matignon à
l'elysée
non non non colère et ancien directeur
du trésor et la voilà donc on voit bien
qu'à l'heure de la vérité c'est bercy et
le trésor qui donne le la de la
politique l'a effectivement hulot a des
bonnes raisons de penser qu'il a servi
de caution électorale alors il faut
qu'il reste très important parce que si
ça va ça sera pire si ça va maintenant
notre dame des landes sera sera
probablement fait cirest et au moins il
se sacrifiera c'est le piranha qu'on
jette c'est le buzz quand j'étais au
profit à la porte le troupeau de visites
de 2,3 des fleurs aussi est-ce que lui
loue à votre avis les moyens de changer
le modèle agricole français parce qu'il
est venu avec 7,7 ambitions avant de
réaction de d'abord djamel je souhaite
le départ de nicolas hulot car il m'a
énormément déçu nombreux voyants lui une
personne sérieuse responsable exemplaire
engagé pour tout ce qui concerne
l'écologie mais je me suis senti trahi
son comportement face aux problèmes des
glyphosate des loups de la chasse le
fait qu'il ait une collection de
voitures ont fini de me convaincre qu'il
était sûr et fumiers
certes son travail n'était pas facile
mais il aurait pu faire beaucoup de
choses pour faire progresser l'écologie
et hugo gagneux qui est qui est aussi
que titi la sphère de la voiture des
codes des voitures nicolas hulot
apparemment tu n'écris hulot est le
symbole de la gauche bien pensante non
voiture thermique mais il y en a je ne
sais combien fais ce que je dis pas ce
que je fais
pour revenir à son ambition lorsqu'ils
arrivent et il pensait vraiment pouvoir
changer le modèle ultra productiviste le
problème de nicolas hulot c'est que
depuis des années il est fustigée par
les écologistes même et par les écolos
dure aux mêmes normes parce que il a nié
cette image très médiatique ushuaïa et
c'est juste passion qu'ils connaissent
grand-chose à l'agriculture française
j'ai pas sûr qu'il ait vraiment une
colonne vertébrale idéologique ces
sujets donc c'était c'était une
nomination très médiatique qui aurait pu
servir à quelque chose impulse est en
effet un mouvement simplement elle dans
un gouvernement qui n'a pas du tout
cette priorité qui est en effet libérale
et qui veut accentuer le libre échange
notamment via le cette année par exemple
il a accepté
paris l'a dit pendant la ratification du
sénat par le parlement national
on pourra peut-être mettre en oeuvre un
veto climatique reste à voir ce sujet
s'il va pouvoir mettre en oeuvre j'en
doute fortement
et c'est vrai que là pour moi la
couleuvre la plus la plus abominable qui
l'a acquis là qu'il avalise celle du
ceta parce que c'est vraiment pour le
coup à une régression écologie et le
nucléaire en effet mais y avait il y
avait je pense que dans le nucléaire y
avait une arrivée ou une un panier
d'incapacité pratiques à mettre en
oeuvre la le sénat y avait vraiment
aucune voulons à aucun volontarisme ne
va jamais grand jeu a le sentiment que
emmanuel macron a choisi nicolas hulot
pour des raisons peut-être aussi de
notoriété parce qu'il sait qu'il est
très populaire et je crois qu'il est
toujours très populaire dans les
sondages nicolas hulot malgré ces bois
qu'ils avalent quasiment toutes les
semaines
ah si on prend l'ensemble du
gouvernement c'est d'abord dont ceux qui
ont le plus de notoriété de notoriété et
en plus il est très il est très
populaire
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde les
réseaux sociaux on s'aperçoit qu'on lui
pardonne tout même l'histoire des
voitures même l'histoire du fait
voilà d'avoir gagné de l'argent quand il
était évidemment producteurs de tout ça
finalement ce n'est pas un problème il
reste l'un des ministres pourquoi les
plus les plus populaires et finalement
la question qui se pose c'est quel est
son rôle
et quand on creuse en fait sa popularité
on s'aperçoit qu'il est aussi populaire
au niveau 2 des écolos et donc c'est pas
très compliqué c'est le maintien
les écolos d'accord c'est un rempart
c'est un rempart à l'écologie pour un
gouvernement qui est pas toujours très
très
eco friendly mais où grands et qui peut
rester toujours sur cette ligne ambiguë
pour ne pas dire plus pendant encore
bien géré mais il ya un moment il ya une
vague avoir forme de compromis est
trouvé et donc forcément d'arbitrage
entre nicolas hulot qui est sa notoriété
très forte équipe après d'ailleurs de de
baisser en tout cas si on en voit
aujourd'hui des cours vous délectant
dans ce n'est pas près de se battre et
de baisser et puis finalement le fait
qu'il ya des événements sur lequel il va
falloir qu'ils se positionnent notre
dame des landes on en est un plus
l'accumulation de tout ce qui s'est
passé avant donc il ya un moment c'est
lui qui va se retrouver dans une
situation de porte-à-faux visiblement un
développement visiblement visiblement
c'est pas mal de séquences garde-fous et
si emmanuel macron a voulu la voir avec
la question ça c'est bon là visiblement
les indications qu'on a c'est plutôt que
mallory fait du tout notre temps mais
plutôt intérêts soyons très prudents et
ils tant qu'il sera là ça sera dans ce
sens toujours il sera plus là ce sera
non est ce qui peut changer la question
est ce qui peut changer le modèle
agricole français
il faut le changer d'urgence notamment
dans un changement de comportement de
consommation au coeur duquel la grande
distribution se trouve d'une façon
absolument
j'allais dire est chaotique
catastrophique
donc il va essayer le peut il fera je
suis sure they know ping à chacun porte
qu'un chasse aux noirs ou gris
pourvu qu'il attrape des souris hulot
aura apporté quelque chose peut-être pas
tout ce qu'il ambitionnait tout ce qu'il
fait tout ce qu'il voulait mais il a
apporté le jour il partira ça sera pire
alors le problème c'est qu'il ait marqué
à la culotte par un ministre c'est un
travers qui est là pour s'assurer que ça
n'aille pas trop loin en fait c'est
l'agriculture qu'on aurait dû donner à
nicolas hulot même si le rallye
compétition les cabinets on arriverait à
faire il faut faire vite parce que la
culture française aujourd'hui elle est à
un point de non retour
si dans les quelques mois qui arrivent
des mesures concrètes courageuse
douloureuse ne sont pas prises sur cette
redistribution des richesses l'aide
européenne
naples 1 prend des des produits
phytosanitaires avec le fn et soeurs qui
est quand même
la vérité c'est quoi c'est que stéphane
le foll avait exclu la fnsea de la
cogestion du ministre la culture qu'elle
co gérée depuis 50 ans avec stéphane
travert christiane lambert revenir ij la
culture française tels que c'est
toujours passer si on va dans ses
directives et même si la fnsea me déjà
les dires de l'eau dans son vin
il ya quand même des réformes difficiles
à faire par rapport au système
économique est prescrit emmanuel macron
là ils sont en contradiction et la
réforme écologique que prenez nicolas
hulot était une voie par laquelle avec
le tube france on a comme le sentiment
qu'il doit refuser de vérité un trait là
c'est l'heure de vérité s'il a dans
l'année qui arrive dans les mois on a vu
les déclarations d'edouard philippe hier
6 restée déclarations des incantations
on le verra très vite et c'est même je
veux dire c'est l'avenir du quinquennat
et la réélection des manuels macron qui
est en jeu s'il ne donne pas des signes
probatoire précis là-dessus
l'opinion publique pensera que l'on se
trompe et en 2010 à dugny bastien
dernier mot
me manqueront donc il s'en rend compte
qu'il a beaucoup d'actifs il se rend
compte que eux justement depuis qu'il
est lui qu il va à la conquête de la
france périphérie alors allez on va voir
si en effet c'est suivi d'effet mais
pour le moment mais finalement c'est le
bilan de nicolas hulot gouvernement
c'est quoi précisément il n'a pas de
quelle mesure qu'elle quels chantiers
qu'elle la décision c'est tout bilan du
gouvernement
pour l'instant on est dans des
déclarations oui ça fonctionne à des
projets nicolas hulot par rapport à
l'offensive de blanquette ou est ce qui
se passe là votre oeil était largement
de ça je parlais des promesses par
rapport à des enjeux là le travail
c'était justement le problème d'un
conflit justement système économique
donc il était dans son rôle mais nicolas
hulot a fait d emmanuel macron a fait
des promesses qu'ils n'étaient pas
forcément conforme à sa vision
économique de la france est là on
l'attend quelles concessions m'a dit de
faire pour l'instant chaque fois
qu'elles ont été mis sur la table on a
fait marche arrière
donc pour quelqu'un qui n'avait jamais
fait de politique c'est un bombe l'été
les promesses qu'il ne tient pas donc on
est rentré tout de suite c'est pas un
vrai polar
oui voilà qu'il soit meilleur que vrai
encore une promesse qu'a faite
emmanuel macron il n'y a pas très
longtemps c'est à propos de la
télévision publique un sujet qui
semblait tenir à coeur du dollar selon
l'express il aurait dit que c'était la
honte de la république à la patrie mais
complicité la gestion l'organisation de
la télévision publique en tout cas il a
évoqué son avenir dans son interview
toujours avec laurent delahousse sur
france 2 et bien que quelques jours on
écoute les plus jeunes ils regardent de
moins en moins la télévision sur le plan
linéaire et notre audiovisuel public
aujourd'hui il reste structuré dans sa
géographie avec un grand système de
radio un grand système de télévision qui
certes se sont mis aux digital mais ils
essaient structuré dans son architecture
un peu sur le monde d'avant il n'a pas
suivi ce changement l'audiovisuel public
français c'est de très loin pour l'état
le premier budget de la culture
donc il ya de l'argent simplement est ce
qu'on le met au bon endroit et ce qu'on
soit surtout l'organisation collective
qui est la plus pertinente up ou
françoise nyssen la ministre de la
culture a déclaré vouloir également
ouvrir un chantier à ce sujet
au mois de janvier c'est pas la première
fois jamais me range qu'on a ce débat
sur la télévision publique française est
elle trop médiocre est elle trop cher on
a l'impression que c'est une vieille
histoire
alors c'est des histoires mais surtout
c'est que les les usages ou ont changé
et c'est à dire que l'âge d'or de la
télévision est un peu révolu et
notamment sous deux courses ou deux
grandes forces
la première des forces c'est
l'internationalisation du monde et
notamment des programmes et donc avec
comme point d'orgue les séries on est un
des rares pays dans lequel les séries
étrangères et notamment américaines ont
plu audience que les séries nationales
et puis la deuxième chose c'est la
manière dont on consomme la télévision
et avec évidemment internet
même si aujourd'hui on consomme toujours
3h40 train de télévision par jour
il se trouve que la nature de cette
consommation a changé avec finalement
une dimension familiale deux on est plus
on n'est plus devant le poste de
télévision
on va plus avoir d usage individuel
chacun avec sa tablette avec son
smartphone à vouloir prendre un
programme plutôt qu'un autre et donc et
donc ça aujourd'hui
ça nécessite une adaptation très clair
2 comment dire de la politique publique
à la rédaction c'est comment s'adapter
ils ont public et voilà comment on le
fait daniel bilalian vous qui êtes du
monde d'avant et qui avait connu la
télévision publique
j'ajouterai ce que vous venez de dire
que les plus jeunes d'entre nous ne
regarde pas simplement sur autre chose
qu'à lyon il ne regarde pas toutes les
missions ils ne regardent qu'une partie
de ce qu'on leur a dit c'est-à-dire a
même pas la totalité mais un sketch ou
bien un moment donc ça deviendra m'a dit
moi ce qui moi je suis d'accord avec
monsieur macron sauf que ça concerne
toutes les télévisions et pas simplement
les lieux publics
tf1 est démodé m6 est démodé toutes les
télévisions sont démodés et mais pour ce
qui concerne france et vision que je
connais un tout petit peu je veux dire
le problème de la gouvernance de france
télévisions il se pose pas de la manière
dont il l'a poussé c'est simplement que
c'est ce groupe france télévisions est
bien jusque dans les années 95 avait un
président nommé par les politiques pour
trois ans seulement est désormais cinq
ans et jamais aucun d'entre eux avant
des mois bien jamais aucun d'entre eux
n'a été renouvelé
comment voulez vous gouverner une
entreprise si votre limite de temps ces
trois ans et cinq ans et pourtant
je veux dire si nous existons encore
c'est que c'est pas que nous sommes bons
c'est que les autres ne sont pas si bons
que ça c'est ça le vrai problème
deuxièmement pour ce qui concerne france
télévisions il y avait des choses
simples à faire en dehors d'aller vers
le digital et caetera et de répéter ce
que vous avez dit à l'instant c'est
simplement il ya des économies à faire
mais quand vous parler d'économie par
exemple les députés à paris qui viennent
des régions bouddhiste faut faire des
économies sur france 3 mais si sur le
quai de la gare de nantes ou de lens ou
de lille il n'y a pas un journaliste de
france 3 pour venir les accueillir ils
se demandent comment ils vont être réélu
donc si on pas une contradiction près
ensuite quand vous proposer des
économies en faisant des choses simples
ça il ya eu beaucoup de de patron des
lions qui étaient des anciens de l'ena
vous savez de réponse à l'ena pour pas
le faire c'est ce n'est pas aussi simple
que vous le pensez c'est à dire je me
dégonfle où c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que vous l'imaginez vous avez
deux variantes c'est la même chose on va
rien faire je suis pas là pour longtemps
vous n'avez pas m'emmerder 1 par exemple
qu'en france ô qui coûte plus de 30
millions par an aujourd'hui
france ô ce sont les députés ultramarins
qui est dit nous ne voulons pas du
france ô que nous avons fait avec vos
programmes nous volions simplement ce
que soient retransmises en france les
bulletins d'information des territoires
et départements d'outre-mer premier
budget de france au camp ça a été créé 4
millions d'euros voilà donc voilà des
choses simples mais venir ils ne font
même pas ce que demande
on ne fait même pas ce que demandent les
gens là il y aurait même pas eu ce
problème dont on a besoin 50 millions
d'économies cette année moi je vous en
ai trouvé 30 donc perry qu il manque 20
millions à trouver la république et
outrancière mais elle est fondée je
respecte mes confrères et collègues
la télévision française nicolas de
l'appel il s'est quand même en dhr c'est
quand même un mammouth d'avoir c'est
vrai que tous les médias sont confrontés
aux mêmes dérives au même
clivages c'est quand même un mood dans
lesquelles il ya des gabegies mais
abominable faut le dire ce qui est je
sais que l'intérieur de france2 france3
de service public et des gens qui
partagent cet avis france ô c'est un
scandale
on va pas détailler ici c'est un
scandale donc il a beau jeu de dire mais
je sais comment ça va se finir ça va se
finir toujours qu'un pouvoir exécutif a
le dernier mot alors il paraît que ce
n'est plus le csa qui va nommer une
résidents mais ce sera conseil
d'administration qui l'a mais par qui
les actionnaires et le gouvernement
nous allons tout simplement insister
probablement je veux pas être trop je
n'avais eu lieu à la macro nisation du
service public qui va mettre 40 mais
qu'à lui et tout sera bien ficelé et
bien ficelé ont considéré que la réforme
ait fait ça s'arrêtera là bas tous les
jeunes tous les présidents de la
république qui ont voulu ma chronique et
à leur façon se sont révélés ça a
toujours été une mauvaise initiative
parce que plus vous demander de dire
j'ai connu l'époque
moi je les années 80 etc etc où on
disait la télévision est au service de
monsieur giscard d'estaing est au
service d'un seul avoir la forme mais
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus vrai le moment
où cette rupture a eu lieu c'est la
cohabitation chirac mitterrand de 86 88
cette fois ci les journalistes du
service public ont pris leur
indépendance les gens et du service
public qui sont largement aussi
indépendant que les autres je vois
comment son service de communication
gère la relation avec les médias on est
quand même dans une autorité politique
d'avoir un avis
il est qui l'éloigné journalistes et il
ya quand même beaucoup de coups de
téléphone aujourd'hui qu'ils partent
d'elysée vers les médias pour manifester
du mécontentement ou de l'irritation
donc il va y avoir une mainmise et une
mise en ordre il a une irritation envers
la presse et je pense que les services
publics sera un service public qui sera
mis à pied et aux autres que je n'y vais
si un problème de gabegie dont a parlé
périco légasse mais aussi un problème de
programmes tout simplement l'instant on
est en droit nous qui payons la
redevance d'exiger des programmes de
meilleure qualité c'est quand même aussi
la musique
on entend il leur reproche qu'on fait à
la clé des supports en fait un peu
d'importance si ça va sur internet aussi
ça va sur la télévision
finalement ça a peu d'importance qui
compte c'est le contenu
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui dans un
dans un écosystème où il ya énormément
de chaînes en gratuit je crois qu'il ya
27 canaux gratuits
quel peut être le rôle de la télévision
expliquer ce que c'est de faire la même
chose que les chaînes privées je ne
crois pas il y avait trois missions du
service public au départ s'étaient
informés cultivé et distraire
aujourd'hui je pense que distraire on
pourrait s'en passer parce que c'est pas
enfin ce n'est pas on pourrait se passer
de nagui et de patrick sébastien
honnêtement sur service public sachant
que c'est très bien mis en oeuvre par
tf1 par tmc par nrj12 et donc mais
posons une chaîne service est un service
public qui soit qui ait pour objectif
d'informer d'une part et de et de
cultiver comme la vie ici finalement la
bbc est ce qu'on va venir à sa guise en
là c'est d'abord your knees en oublier
de parler mais c'est le cas de sarkozy
dans les années 2007 veut dire supprimer
la publicité pour rendre service à
bouygues
je n'ai pas inventé ça parce que j'ai
moi j'étais en réunion des directeurs
on est en train de parler du budget
publicitaire des années à venir et
quelqu'un était entré en disant il ya
plus de publicité 501 dont on peut pas
dire qu'on était vraiment informé ça
c'est un sale coup sur les finances d'un
dingo comme contre parce que à son goût
dit il faudrait simplement faire des
programmes différents mais à ce moment
là que va reprocher au gouvernement
c'est vous ne faites pas suffisamment
d'audience quand vous voyez qui pour
faire de l'audience pour faire hanouna
et s'envoyer ddd ball et de louer dans
le caleçon pour faire rire les gens
mais plusieurs l'air d'apprécier parce
qu'ils en ont il faut aussi dedans alors
dans leur adaptation systématique à la
demande essayer de proposer une offre
et s'il ya des problèmes aussi à la
déménager à manchester mais la fin une
grande forme frimas heures aujourd'hui
que ce soir ou jamais était supprimée de
france 2 par exemple était la seule
élection il y avait un débat pluraliste
démission de frédéric taddeï où il y
avait un vrai débat de fond pluraliste
qui a déjà été décalé à 22 eur puis à
22h30 puis à 23 heures puis finalement
supprimé aujourd'hui il n'ya plus
l'équivalent sur la chaîne publique
c'est un scandale s'est longtemps je
n'annonce et d'un scandale financier si
à mes propositions il y aura pas de gens
qui reviendront évidemment de
l'audiovisuel public dans son ensemble
il ya aussi un certain nombre
d'institutions qui concourent à ça et
moi je ne sais en muscles à titre
d'illustration le cnc le cnc aujourd'hui
manipule 260 millions d'euros et
participe à travers la manière dont il
investit dans les différentes oeuvres à
une forme de hiérarchisation culturel
parce que très vite quand on parle
audiovisuelle très vite on est en train
de parler de la partie culturelle qui
est à la fois un accélérateur mais aussi
un frein au fait de faire quelque chose
et donc le cnc par exemple ne participe
à aucune aucun financement de programmes
de flux
c'est un choix par contre surpondérer
documentaire est ce que les programmes
de flux répondent à comment dire à ce
qu'attendent les comment dire le public
est ce que les documentaires sont
aujourd'hui répondent aussi à cette
tâche ça c'est ainsi un point après il
ya le sujet de la manière dont on
transforme les choses de comment parce
que si on est d'accord pour dire oui il
ya peut-être un moment un petit point
fixe à faire et à se poser la question
de finalement sur le rôle de cet odieux
lisez le public la question c'est
comment
et là je pense que la vraie erreur qu'il
faudrait pas commettre c'est c'est
peut-être celle commencé avec une idée
préconçue et je pense que ça mérite là
pour le coup parce que tous les
prédécesseurs ont dit voilà je pense que
c'est comme ça où il faut faire comme ça
ou alors on fait comme ça qui finalement
derrière on essaye de récupérer et
d'avoir la mainmise et finalement pour
une fois je pense qu'on ne franchira pas
d'un vrai dire nos stic de deux caisses
captant le public qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent les journalistes qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent finalement l'ensemble
des professionnels de l'audiovisuel
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on attend comme
sens du de l'audiovisuel public est fort
de ça je pense qu'on sera à même d'avoir
un point de départ pour une
transformation jeu
pas qu'on nous rende tout de suite
pierre desgraupes sainte eline vis à vis
des lasers je pense que l'épée de
maintien dernier mot danny danon
heureusement que les français pensent je
pense dans leur généralité que la
redevance sert à avoir la télévision
simplement si jamais il s'apercevrait
que s'est pas uni c'est uniquement pour
le service public comme la vigne
il est fait pour lui c'est sur ces mots
pleins de sagesse de daniel bilalian
périco légasse que je remercie acquis
ainsi que jenny bastié et benjamin
grange que nous nous quittons c'était le
dernier point de vue de l'année 2017
nous nous retrouvons l'année prochaine
dès le lundi 8 janvier avec guillaume
roquette
aux manettes que les fans de guillaume
roquette se rassure vous allez pouvoir
le voir l'entendre et le dévorer des
yeux tout de suite avec eric zemmour qui
l'interrogent sur cette tendance de
notre société a stigmatisé
systématiquement sous différents
prétextes le mâle blanc hétérosexuel de
plus de 50 ans un vaste sujet si l'on
est bonsoir à tous et à l'année
prochaine
[Musique]